Hey,
what's going on is bill burn is type of the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Ah,
just checking in on you.
Ooh,
I'm just checking in on you to see how your work weeks go.
And you know,
fucking weird one this year with 4th of July on a Wednesday.
You know,
if it's on the Tuesday,
maybe your boss gives you the Monday off,
right?
You got a three day fucking week after a four day weekend.
It's beautiful.
You know,
it's on Thursday.
Maybe you don't have to come in Friday.
There's your four day fucking weekend.
Not this year.
Oh No.
Oh,
fucking powdered wig itself came in on a Wednesday.
Fucked everybody Monday.
Tuesday.
Right?
Everybody fucks off for Wednesday.
Now you gotta come back Thursday,
Friday.
It's cool to get the day off,
but she didn't get the consecutive days off,
you know?
Do you know he got fucked up the night of July 3rd,
right?
And yesterday.
What'd you do?
You ate a bunch of fucking burgers.
Is that what you did?
Uh,
I am finally on the other side of this.
God damn cold.
I caught one of these post global warming,
Mother Nature is going to start getting rid of us cold,
this fucking thing.
Okay.
It came on slow,
you know,
and then it just started picking up speed and it just grabbed me by the fucking
throat and just choke slammed me.
Uh,
okay.
Yeah.
So I'm finally,
finally on the other side of it though.
He wouldn't know what to hear me right now,
but I am,
uh,
I want to thank all you guys for your postcards and your well wishes
meant a lot to me.
You know,
when I was sitting in the lay there in the hospital bed,
uh,
I actually was the first guy who ever went to the hospital for a common cold and
the San Fernando Fernando Valley area,
they made a plaque for me and everything.
I went in there and the doctor was just like looking at my chart.
If I looked up,
he's like,
so you got the sniffles?
And I was like,
yeah.
He's like,
you know,
I have a whole emergency room full of people that got stabbed and shot.
And I was like,
yeah,
I know,
but like one of my nostrils,
it's like really clogged up and I just can't like deal man.
Um,
I tell you guys,
I saw that,
that documentary on Mark Ronson,
is that his name?
No,
not mark Ronson.
The fucking guy who played with David Bowie is Mark Ronson,
the Guy Mick Ronson broths and it's still one mark Ronson.
Is this is your mother,
your father,
your sister,
whatever that fucking song is this Jalyn by eight and some peanut butter.
It's a fucking summer.
Dabba do let me see your titties.
All right.
Isn't that how that song went?
Uh,
Mick
played with David Bowie when he was Ziggy stardust and the spiders and I'm
fucking incredible guitarist.
Credible musician,
a producer wrote songs,
you know,
learn how to write out all the music and all this shit.
And he got no fucking credit.
Got No fucking credit,
didn't get any money.
They fucked him.
I just,
the music business is the absolute worst.
I can't tell you how many fucking times I've seen that.
You know,
the drummer and the bass player in those first two Ozzie Solo albums,
like they just,
they just fuck those guys.
They just,
you know,
guys coming in and writing rifts and writing entire fucking songs,
but they're too,
they don't have a good lawyer.
Nobody tells him what's up.
They don't get the,
uh,
you know,
and then it's like song by Ozzy Osborne and then they get fucked out of millions
of dollars.
How do you do that to a kid?
It's just this reoccurring thing in the fucking music business is fucking guy
was writing all these rifts.
He was writing the string arrangements.
He was in the fucking studio with one of those conductor once they didn't,
you didn't get any fucking credit.
Okay.
It's fucking pro.
Uh,
but what was amazing was watching the guy,
uh,
I saw him,
I was like,
Jesus Christ,
that guy looks like fucking Randy Rhoads same haircut,
same fucking Les Paul and all that.
I'm like,
wait,
Randy Rhodes came after Mick Ronson.
So then I just look googled.
Randy Rhoads,
a Mick Ronson influenced and a bunch of shit came out and saying that he was a
fan of yours.
I thought that was pretty cool,
you know,
and already had more of the classical guitar type of stuff in there.
But,
you know,
say uh,
it's a,
yeah,
it's a good documentary.
I saw it on a plane though.
You know,
whenever you want to play it.
Every,
everything's fucking good guys.
I don't know it,
I fucking,
I'm,
I'm still,
I'm coming out of this shit man.
You know,
I don't know what it feels like to be trapped in a mine.
I'll fucker,
there's some kids right now trapped somewhere.
The news is just so brutal.
I just,
I,
when I read,
I just see like the headline,
I just go,
ah,
I just walk away.
I don't know how people just sit there watching other people's suffering.
It's one thing to say,
hey,
these kids are trapped in a mine right over there.
Grab a shovel,
come with me.
Then you can do something.
But they just know this sitting there and there's nothing he can fucking do
about it.
You know,
kind of fucked up a bunch of kids end up in a mind.
Is that what happened?
The end of mind and a fucking stuck on a giant lily pad or something like that
in the middle of the river.
I don't know.
I bet an uh,
you know,
I've been like fucking hallucinating,
no God damn week.
But,
uh,
one of the good things about being this sick as I haven't drank in like fucking
five days,
you know,
and uh,
I got some active work next week,
so whenever I got an acting work,
I shut down all the fun,
you know.
Oh Billy,
no fund,
you know,
try to keep my face not fucking,
I'll fucking puffy and shit.
Um,
so anyways.
Oh God,
I got nothing.
Jesus Christ.
They got nothing,
but I got to knock this up.
Hmm.
This is how funny I am.
What?
I'm fucking sick for five days.
I'm basically not funny at all.
Okay.
I would appreciate it if you guys would just cut me a little bit of fuck slack.
All right.
You know what I had?
I had a few,
uh,
I fucked up.
Uh,
what else?
Uploading the Monday morning podcast when uh,
like kill my,
the battery on my laptop died.
So 15 minutes in the middle got cut out.
So we had to edit it,
edit it together.
So there's some fucking people wrote in some questions that I'm going to re
answer them the best I can.
By the way on Instagram I found this account that I've been following called
don't be a Brad and it's basically a trashing like essentially a meathead white
guy,
frat boys.
Um,
you know it's funny,
they kind of,
you know,
it's hilarious because you know,
there's a lot of truth to it.
But then also it's like you completely judging these people by their skin color
and nobody gives a fuck cause it's fucking white guys.
But a lot of them are just really good looking guys who are in frats and they're
getting a lot of pussy and your fucking annoyed by it because you're a nerd.
So you started this account.
Having said that,
it is funny,
like they literally have one of them yelling at about Sicko.
Do you know what my dad does?
You know what,
everybody makes fun of these Frat kids.
It's not their fucking fault.
It's the parents.
It's like making fun of millennials.
It's like it's not,
it's the people who raised him that fucked him up.
But it's a very funny account.
I'll be it.
A lot of it,
you know,
it's just unathletic people making fun of people who are athletic.
Um,
and then there's also something too,
you know,
there's a curse to be in fucking good looking.
You know,
I was reading this one time,
this article in rolling stone and this guy who was just like this heartthrob for
fucking 15 years was now like in his sixties and he was still in this fucking,
this interview and they were talking to him and he was reflecting on what kind
of a person he was back in his twenties in his thirties he said,
well,
you know,
I was,
he was basically saying he was a really good looking guy.
He was on a TV show and in movies and he had a big Dick.
So he only had to develop so much as a human being.
It was really fascinating.
So then when he got old and he wasn't as good looking,
it was creepy to younger women and shit.
He actually had to finish developing all development as a human that he never
had to do before because all he did was just show up in all the women fainted.
They pulled out his giant Dick.
You know what he fucking went to tout it was dealt with.
Daddy went back down to the movie set and made another hit movie.
It was very,
very interesting.
So I actually was thinking of that when I was looking at that.
Don't be a bread,
uh,
Instagram account.
Well,
it's like this isn't these kids 100% their fault.
Like if your kid is walking around and acted like an asshole and then go and do
you know what my dad does for a living?
Uh,
you spoiled the shit out of that kid.
That's your fucking fault.
That,
I mean,
that's complete failure.
Okay.
As a dad.
If your kids out there be it a fucking,
you know,
mouthing off to some bounce or that could fucking twist them up like a pretzel
and then screaming like,
my dad's going to come down here.
Oh my God,
I just be like son,
son.
Fight your own battles.
Like what are you doing?
I want to come down here.
We'll do what?
Sue Him cause you're a fucking asshole.
I don't want to see you get a concussion but he should have slapped the shit out
of you.
All right.
Republican douche
question mark.
Uh Hey bill,
I'm a fan of your comedy.
I'm still a fan of you,
but artists that you're starting to sound like a red pill,
Republican Douche bag,
you know,
is it just classically classic like way that looked like politics is discussed
now.
You know,
like his whole thing is called Republican douchey question mark.
I like,
I don't understand these people where if,
if you're a republican that automatically you're a Douche.
If you're a Democrat you're automatically at,
do you know what I mean?
You know what I'm saying?
Like,
like,
you don't think anybody on either.
Like everybody on that side is just douche bags.
Um,
anyways,
he goes,
no offense,
you're always going on about how Hillary is evil.
Well,
our country is going down the shitter and she would've saved us from a lot of
these headaches.
All right,
well that's pretty vague.
Okay.
Our country has been going down the shitter for a long time,
sir.
I don't know what you're talking about.
What exactly wasn't it going down the Shitter,
you know?
Oh,
speaking of that,
you know,
back in the,
uh,
of that fucking don't be a Brad,
one of the frat boys had Ronald Reagan tattooed on his calf.
Not a picture.
It just said Ronald Reagan that fuck it was,
that's hilarious to me.
You know,
Ronald Reagan is like rich white people's Abraham Lincoln.
Like he set them free in a way by,
you know,
by,
deregulating everything.
So then these fucking robber barons could get back to what the fuck they wanted
to be doing.
MMM.
Oh,
look at that.
I just made fun of a Republican,
sir.
Uh,
do I sound like a red pill?
Republican Douche bag?
I mean,
this guy,
he's like literally speaking in sound bites.
Like how fucking like how boring a conversation.
What did to discuss politics with this person?
Um,
anyways,
he say you say you don't like trout Trump,
but you sound like a closet fan who's just too afraid to say you love him cause
you'll lose a part donut store.
Employee number two.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Missed a word in there buddy.
Um,
I'm not afraid to say that I like Trump.
If I like Trump,
I don't like them.
I don't like him and his fucking wife.
The fact that she wore that jacket that said I don't really care.
Do you,
when she was going to see those kids and then tried to say like,
oh,
that had to do with fake news like this,
such passive aggressive fucking pussies.
Yeah.
That had nothing to do with fake news.
Like you telling me nobody at the White House.
This is about fake news.
Well a,
just to let you know,
they are first lady.
People might think you're talking about the kids.
You might not want to wear that.
It was such like a fucking,
you know,
it's bad enough when a guy's at Agora bought a woman does it?
She's actually had kids.
She knows what it's like to have a fucking kid and to sit there and have these
kids in fucking cages and she wears a jacket like that.
It's just that I was fucking,
they're not human.
So anyways,
uh,
he said,
I can't tell if it's set.
Your fan base is all a bunch of moderate morons.
Okay.
Who would rather be concise contrarians that pick the good guys are the bad
guys.
Why don't you just pick a side because clearly this is a good guy,
bad guy thing going on here.
Question Mark.
Uh,
that's probably one of the most ignorant,
condescending fucking emails I've ever gotten.
You didn't make one fucking point.
You just spoken big broad soundbites.
I get it.
You're a Democrat and you think everybody was a republican is a Douche,
eh,
the country's going down the shitter.
And if we picked a Democrat,
it wouldn't be going down the shitter.
And there are good guys.
And there are bad guys and the good guys are Democrats are the bad guys are
Republicans.
Right?
Hey,
by the way,
did you see the house,
the Obama's just fucking bought,
you know,
how the fuck did they have the money to buy that fucking house?
Explain that to me.
You know,
every fucking one of them,
whether you wear a blue tie or a red tie,
they come out of the White House worth fucking,
you know,
tens of millions of dollars other than Bill Clinton because he stuck his cigar,
that woman's Pussy and he had a lot of fucking legal bills.
Uh,
but even they,
even the fucking Clinton set it up with me and hundreds of billions.
Well actually Bill Clinton said he came out of the White House in debt,
but he also said I did not have sex with that woman.
So he probably had fucking millions of dollars.
I don't like any of them,
sir.
I don't,
uh,
I liked,
Bernie Sanders.
I liked about saying he would have solved everything,
but uh,
God knows.
See Gabby,
he,
he got,
he got the majority of the vote and the Democrats said,
fuck that.
We're still giving the Dobbin the domination to Hillary.
And she was fine with that.
That had the fucking nerve to sit there and bitch about the fucking election.
Uh,
that last election was to aim at a bar,
sir.
There was no,
there was no wedding.
There was no winning.
That one.
Uh,
I mean,
Hillary literally sent in 2008 to the bankers.
Don't worry.
I got you guys.
Like I'll basically cover if you guys,
I mean,
you should be tried for fucking trees and when you do shit like that,
uh,
I don't see any difference between her or Trump.
I doubt they're complete pieces of shit that are out for themselves,
who act like they're there for you.
And it's weird if they were a certain color fucking shirt some half the country
believes it.
Uh,
all right.
25 year old buying an old house.
All right.
Hey,
Billy doughboy from 25 years old,
just graduated with my masters and got a dream job,
a dream teaching job in Philly.
You're teaching in Philadelphia where you got your work cut out for you,
fucking with you.
MMM.
Anyways,
I got my dream job teaching in Philadelphia.
Where the fuck did it just go?
I just lost everything here.
Okay.
Oh,
belly.
All right.
Okay.
With how cheap the housing market is,
I figured it would be a smart decision to buy a house now rather than wait 10
years.
Uh,
I found a great old house in Philly.
It's in my price.
Wage should be price range,
move in ready.
It has all the details.
I love about old houses.
They accepted my offer and they close at the end of the month.
That's exciting.
25 years old.
You've got a house,
Dude.
You got your dream job,
you're crushing it.
All you gotta do is pick the right lady and you're good.
You pick the wrong one.
She'll take all of it from,
yeah,
but you won't see that Hashtag on Twitter.
We'll,
yeah.
Uh,
after listening to your podcast for a couple of years,
I know that you have a love hate relationship with your old house.
Yes,
I do.
Is there any advice that you have for me,
for me as I move in and make my first real adult purchase?
Thanks for keeping me and many other teachers saying with your podcast.
Okay.
All right.
Well if you're going to buy an old house,
a Jesus,
I don't even know where to begin.
The first thing I would start with is the guts of the house.
If he,
if he got the money,
if you can redo the electrical and the plumbing or find out to what extent it
has been redone because I had a bunch of cloth wiring and galvanized pipes in my
walls.
You don't want to fire and you don't want to get flooded.
So that's usually a big thing there.
Um,
okay.
I also had a minor gas leak.
It might want to look for stuff like that once you get to the guts.
Okay.
That I would deal with the,
as far as,
um,
you know,
there's going to be a bunch of Shit,
I check out your roof.
That's another thing I would check for termites.
That's another thing.
MMM.
I actually have all like the skeleton keys for every door in the house that I
got them.
So they all work and then within two and a half,
three years of doing it,
the house settled some more.
And now most of the bolts don't line up with the thing.
And I just,
I just stopped fighting the house after a while.
It's just like,
all right,
I get it.
This house is almost a hundred years old and,
uh,
it's going to do what the fuck it wants to do.
So,
um,
I would just,
you know,
once you get the electrical,
the plumbing done,
that's like the biggest thing,
then you can slowly kind of fix up everything else.
But a,
and what I tried to do is,
uh,
you know,
as I upgrade,
like,
you know,
upgrade the electrical and the plumbing,
nobody's going to see that.
So,
you know,
fuck with the character of the house.
But like,
uh,
the worst,
the worst thing you can do is,
is to take stuff out of your house and replace it with Home Depot Shit.
Um,
I would find some sort of old school hardware store that has just that,
those old doors from the time of your house,
you can find those places.
They'll have all the door knobs and all the locks and all of that shit.
You congratulate.
Just go room by room and Redo it.
Um,
yeah.
What's,
you're fine with your old doors.
Not only the an odd size,
they're also really heavy because,
um,
back then
the trees they were cutting down were much older.
It's not wet wood or something.
It's more dense wood.
I don't really understand it,
but they're super heavy as opposed to all these shit would fucking crap that
they have down at the,
uh,
home depot.
And the worst thing,
what I like about your email is that you actually seem to love old houses
because there's nothing worse than someone who doesn't give a fuck about it.
Old House buys it just to flip it.
And it's funny as they got the house to give it a makeover and everything,
the guys that got it keep all the shit and then they take it down to those
hardware stores and they sell it and that assholes like me.
You have to fucking buy it back to fucking make the house look right again.
Um,
all right.
That's my advice.
My advice is the plumbing,
the electrical and your roof.
That's what I would start with.
Then you can deal with all the fucking drafts and all the other bullshit.
MMM.
All right.
I'm sorry guys.
My energy's just fuck.
I got nothing.
All right.
French guy with muscular dystrophy looking for lady advice.
Most share William Tet Rouge.
Uh,
what does that my something bill redhead.
I'm a 39 year old man.
Going to take it.
A fancy to this awesome lady.
We sometimes spend time together working on each other's professional and hobby
projects and we lots of fun.
The Times we do hang out together to specify we're not coworkers,
but we have a similar circle of friends.
Here's the catch.
She's 27,
but I'm 39 and have a disease called muscular dystrophy in case you don't know
what it is.
It's a disease similar to the kid in the wheelchair in the Jim Jeffrey show and
set,
uh,
the differences that in my case I'm a hard headed guy,
refused to accept my fate.
It exercise like crazy as a young lad while I still had some muscle mass to be
able to physically function well above expectations up to my adult years.
That's great.
Uh,
it's only showed a little in the way that I've walked,
but that's it.
Also being physically disabled has really,
uh,
maybe learn to not take anything for granted and focus on my strengths,
which is really increased my personality skills and gave me game enough to have
a few great relationships,
not lower my standards and it's worked so far.
All right.
So what is the problem,
sir?
This seems,
it seems all good.
Uh,
anyways,
since I've developed feelings for this 27 year old girl,
I've been hesitant to tell her about it.
If she says no and rejects me,
no big deal.
I've been rejected before.
Like most other guys out there and it's something I can handle.
It's basically going to suck for a couple days tops and everything is fine after
that,
but I guess I'm more afraid if she says yes,
she's still young.
I'm hitting the gym as much as I can to keep myself out of any wheelchair and
crutches and slow this thing down as much as I can.
However,
in the past 10 years,
this disease has really been taking a toll on me,
Jesus Christ,
to think that it's shit that I bitch about this,
someone dealing with this crap.
I feel my body is going downhill to the point that stairs now look like
mountains.
If I fall,
I can't get up on my own,
which is scary to me.
This girl has been single for a while and has been complaining about being
single,
but she's also young and as her whole life ahead of her.
And I'm not sure
if I'm still going to be able to wipe,
be able to wipe my own ass and 10 years and I don't want to put someone through
the same pain in the future as that woman and family guy was married to Joe in
the wheelchair.
Uh,
should I invest my feelings and not regret it,
you know,
so at least I tried,
or should I just keep it to myself and not waste a vital part of her life?
If she does say yes,
Merci beaucoup.
Delaer Amen.
See seizures.
Just sweet frank.
Koebel I don't know what the fuck.
Thanks a lot.
Uh,
and same if I am something.
Yeah,
I don't what does,
just see qual,
ma'am.
I mean,
literally that's I am when?
Same Gross Party.
Okay.
I'm a big fan of the Bruins and I hate the Montreal Canadians with a passion.
He wrote that in French.
You the Tesla Canadians Demario a vacuum passion,
just recall mill or grow participant influence.
Um,
I would fucking tell her everything he said to me.
He said,
listen,
I got fields for you.
I really like your point.
I'm 39 years old.
I had muscular dystrophy.
Yeah.
And I don't want to waste you fucker.
I wouldn't know if I'd say all that.
I'd fucking ask her out.
And then,
you know,
if you guys hit it off then I would say all that other shit,
you know?
Does that make sense?
Just don't dump the whole thing and I don't.
So talk about her having to wipe your ass in 10 years to figure that'd be a
fucking buzzkill.
MMM.
But you know,
you do want to be fucking up front.
I would,
I would think,
uh,
I got a buddy of mine,
his wife's like that.
She's got the same thing.
I tell her she has ms ethic.
So she has like days where she's like super tired and everything.
Uh,
why do I complain about Dumb Shit Life for this?
People like this out there.
Uh,
sir.
I would ask her out.
Okay.
She's a big girl.
She's fucking 27 years old.
All right.
Ask her out.
Do every year.
You're probably fucking live in more in the moment than most people.
Um,
you know,
fuck.
I mean,
life flies by.
Forget about when you're dealing with some shit that you're dealing with.
So,
you know,
you're a good guy.
You're actually care about it.
You know,
she care about another person like that.
You don't want to waste the best part of their life dealing with you.
But,
um,
who knows?
Maybe you guys hit it off,
ask her out,
dude,
ask her out.
You know?
But then it moves on to another level that I would talk about that other stuff
and see what she says.
All right.
Drug dealing roommate.
Well,
this is going to be easy.
Um,
move out or kick them up.
All right.
Hey,
Billy,
ball breaker.
I'm from the,
I'm from right outside of Philly.
Nother one.
Don't hold it against me.
Dom Arrera has a good shit.
I have nothing against Philadelphia.
I just had a fucking tough show there.
Okay.
And I made fun affiliate.
I was somewhere else.
It would have missed the front of somewhere else,
but I don't have a problem with it.
All right.
But I'm 28 and one of my roommates is a deal.
Oh,
congratulations to filling one of the super bowl.
You know,
I,
I can say that now.
The pain's gone away.
Uh,
it was great when I first moved in.
Okay.
At 22 and all I had to do for some pot was walk upstairs,
but now we've sort of grown up and he's pushing some other shit,
which worries me about the safety of our crib.
Should I approach him and ask him to knock it off or just fuck his girlfriend
and then the friendship.
That's hilarious.
Thanks.
And instead of go fuck yourself and wish you the lovely Nia and your baby girl.
Nothing but the best.
See you in AC in October.
Go Birds.
Uh,
go birds.
Is that the Orioles?
Is that the eagles?
There's a lot of birds down there,
man.
Um,
what should you do?
I don't think when somebody is dealing coke.
Uh,
okay.
Heroin.
What else would be up?
The ecstasy.
Okay.
Math.
I don't think you can just say,
hey,
we get knock it off like they have their stereo too loud.
I mean this person has made a decision that this is how they get to earn a
living.
So I would get the fuck out of there is what I would do.
I would not fuck his girlfriend.
Okay.
Cause he might be trying his own fucking drugs is drugs.
Might tell them to do something fucking crazy to you while you're sleeping.
So I would die.
I get the fuck out of there is what I would do.
He goes,
one of these days you're going to be asleep and the door's going to get kicked
in.
It's going to be the cops and you can be fucking face down with a boot and your
back getting fucking handcuffed.
And then he,
then they're going to be like,
did you know he's dealing drugs?
Uh,
no,
he's going to rat you up.
You know,
that's shit.
He used to buy them off me.
Uh,
cause he's a piece of shit.
Well,
maybe he's a good,
when we use a drug dealer with a heart of gold and he gets you out of it.
Yes.
You don't need that the fuck.
Get out of there.
Do you want names on the lease?
Uh,
I would kick him out if he doesn't leave that I would just find someplace else
to live.
Um,
all right.
Let me read a little advertising here.
Oh,
look who's back,
honey.
Billions of people are using hardy to save money while shopping online.
And why wouldn't they?
It's free.
Takes just two clicks to add to your browser and save you a ton of,
saves you tons of money.
It's ingenious.
One of my absolute favorite things about [inaudible] is how much better it makes
shopping on Amazon.
Okay.
Uh,
please personalize this to make it your own.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Hardy magically adds all sorts of useful information,
right on the Amazon page of whatever you're looking at.
Just shop like you normally do.
Hoodie automatically searches.
Hadi automatically searches to 2 million sellers on Amazon to find the lowest
price.
Even shows you item item's prices changes.
So you can decide if you want to buy or wait for the price to come down.
Oh,
they do this on Amazon.
This is like when he's a little fishes,
that sort of mix of the big fish.
The big fish never eats it.
You know,
just sort of tolerated.
If you do decide to wait,
just add hardy drop lists and it will notify you if the price drops.
When Heidi gets you 100 he's got your back.
You'll never overpay for anything on Amazon again.
There's no reason to add hardy to your browser today,
not to add it to your browser,
tay,
it's free.
Just takes two clicks to install and we'll make sure you always get the lowest
price at Amazon.
It's fucking free.
People
add to your browser for free right now to join hardy.com/trends that's joined
hardy.com/hardy
all right,
you got a couple more here.
Porro
you know people after a busy week,
is there anything better than coming home to a comfortable couch?
Trouble.
Is your couches in there comfortable?
Is it maybe you fell for the Scandinavian aesthetic?
Oh,
you know what I actually did?
We bought some fancy fucking couch.
It's stinks.
It's too many pillows.
You just can't even relax on it.
I hate that couch.
Uh,
maybe the cushions lost that pop for owners ago.
Whatever the case you owe it to yourself to experience the comfort of a borough
couch,
uh,
made from murdered donkey,
snow,
kidding borough spring style and comfort to a new level and ships to your door
fast and free.
Your relationship with your couch will never be the same.
Boros Boros Sofas are handcrafted in the same factories in North Carolina is
other high end retailers,
but burrowed delivers them with for much less with their innovative award
winning design it,
it's been arrogant.
I basically designed to allow for multi hour Netflix binges,
triple header game days and late night work sessions.
Customize your borough Surfer Sofa to match your style by selecting the color,
size,
armrest,
height and leg.
Carla,
that's perfect for you.
Shipping is fast and free,
unlike the rest of the furniture industry.
And did we mentioned it has a built in USB charger.
This is fucking ridiculous.
I mean like you used to be like guys like shack would get accustomed couch cause
he's nine feet tall.
The fact that you get to this five foot,
10 inch guy could do this is incredible.
How to nobody think of that before with they use USB charger.
Uh,
enjoy 30 days of cozy,
cozy on your comfortable borough risk-free or try out burrow and one of the
partners showrooms today,
customize your own borough and get $75 off your order by going to [inaudible]
dot com slash bird that's B u r r o w.com/burr for $75 off your purchase borough
makes the luxury couch for real life.
You know,
love that Bobby Kelly.
He would fucking love that.
They should hook them up with a couch.
Dad,
it's got a USB port in it.
Did the IMS is right where my arm is dead.
He would love it.
They would talk it up and they'd sell a whole bunch of them.
I was supposed to me fucking sit here post a bola sweating like a fucking
guy on the first 48.
All right,
hymns.
It wasn't us.
It was hymns.
66% of men lose their hair by age 35 can I tell you guys a fucking hilarious
story?
I was at the laugh factory a couple nights ago
and I get off stage and this guy comes up to me
like he does hair transplant surgery and he's got like his card,
right.
Okay.
When I just realized the volume is way down or this fucking thing.
Hello,
hello,
hello.
So the guy fucking,
he comes up to me after my set,
he goes,
hey man,
I can fix that.
I could fix that.
Talking about my bald head,
and he's got this before and after photos gut.
Now here's the thing I've taught.
This is the third time.
This same guy,
he's approached me all right?
The first time it was,
it was fucking,
I laughed.
It was hilarious.
You know,
cause he said the same thing.
He came up to me,
he goes,
Hey,
I can fix that.
I didn't go to his place and say,
hey man,
I don't like the way I look.
You know,
he just walked up to me and was so convinced that I thought I looked as awful
is.
He evidently thought I looked that he thought it was totally fine to come up to
me and just say,
Hey,
I can fix that,
you know?
And I laughed and I said,
Oh man,
I go,
I'm cool.
I liked the way I look.
You know,
I'm actually getting better roles now that I look.
I look like a fucking,
you know,
before I used to,
I look like howdy doody.
I didn't get good parts.
Now you know,
I get to play fucking assholes because I look like what I always was one,
but I didn't always look like what?
So he's like,
hi.
You know?
Yeah.
That I ran into when I was down in Largo,
same guy.
And I was just like,
Jesus Christ my body.
I'm fire fire,
right?
So anyways,
I was doing Kevin Nealon show
a Tuesday at the laugh factory and I get off stage and this fucking guy comes up
to me again.
He goes,
hey,
you know,
I can fix that.
And he goes,
I'm the best of the business.
First of all,
dude,
if you're the best in the business,
then like,
why are you fucking running up to comics who just got off stage at a comedy club
handing out Your Business Card?
You know,
you like a fucking,
like a,
like a rapper who just started,
who selling mix tapes out of his fucking,
if you're the best in the fucking business,
you know I people should be walking into your office as you pose.
He rushing up to people,
right?
So I said to the guy,
I go,
Jesus Christ,
do I go,
this is a third fucking time he came up to me,
I'm fine the way I look.
I look fine.
He goes,
you look like an area is what he said.
So I finally,
I just kind of snapped a little bit on it,
you know what I mean?
Cause it was like,
it kind of was not funny anymore.
It was just like,
dude,
like
yeah,
you fucking harassing me here.
Okay,
I don't want it.
I'm sorry.
I don't want fucking hair plugs.
What do you do?
You know what it is.
He wants to fuck.
He wants,
he wants a fucking comedian that's got some TV credits that he could do it so
you can be like,
you know,
just,
just as bill bird,
I'll stand there going,
I love my hair products,
you know,
and his fucking commercial so you can go out and get a boat.
Because that's where I felt like he was trying to use me.
You know what I mean?
Try to use my bald head so we could go out and get the fucking boat and the big
tented whore off off of my fucking,
you know,
male pattern baldness.
I thought he was going to use me like,
like fucking Sharon Osborne did to those people on that fucking album.
Shabazz filing.
Yeah.
Do I got,
I got enough money and now for the stupid fucking hair plugs,
they don't,
I don't want your dumb ass hair plugs.
And he's like,
all right,
sorry.
I,
I appreciate what you do.
And I felt bad because he kind of walked away.
But uh,
how funny is that?
He's fucking slinking up to you at a comedy club.
He does hair transplants.
It's like 10 o'clock at night and he's slaking up to me handing my business his
business card.
And he had the fucking nerve to say I'm the best in the business.
The why does this feel so dirty,
sir,
that he's going to fucking ask me if I wanted an abortion.
Uh,
alright.
Hymns wasn't us.
It was hymns.
66% of men lose their hair by the age of 35.
Is that right man?
There's a lot of people out there with hair plugs cause you don't see six out.
It's almost 710 guys.
Thing is when you start to lose you to notice hair loss,
it's too late.
It's easier to keep the hair.
You have to replace the hair you've lost.
I ask you,
why did guys turn to weird solutions or do nothing when they can turn to
medicine in science?
Well cause she just fucking man up and accept your fate.
I don't know.
Uh,
for hims.com a one stop shop for hair loss,
skincare,
sexual wellness for med.
Uh,
thanks to science baldness can be optional is true.
A hymns connects you with real doctors and medical grade solution to treat hair
loss.
No waiting room,
no awkward doctor visits.
Let me sit there and there's all these other balding people in the waiting room.
Save hours by going to four hymns.com a h I m s uh,
answer a few quick questions.
Doctors will review and Ken's prescribe you product products are shipped
directly to your door.
My listeners get a trial month of hymns for just $5 today.
Right now while supplies last.
See websites for full details.
This would cost hundreds if you went to the doctors or a pharmacy,
go to for hims.com/ [inaudible] that's four hymns for h I m s.com/for her,
for him [inaudible] dot com slash bar.
Yeah.
For those of you who don't want to be bald,
personally,
I don't give a shit.
I actually love having a shaved head.
I'm not even gonna lie to Ya.
And I know I look like a freak,
but it's kind of fucking awesome.
Um,
you know,
people think you know Jujitsu,
he don't know Jujitsu,
right?
Um,
hey,
I can help you with that.
Jesus Christ body.
I know I looked bad.
I didn't know I looked that bad that you could just fucking walk.
Right.
I can imagine if he gave boob jobs and he just walked up to subject,
Hey,
can I help you with that?
Now you look terrible when tits go in this way.
The other go the other way.
All right.
Quip.
The truth is most of us are brushing our teeth wrong.
How you brush your teeth wrong,
uh,
not for long enough and forget to change our brush on time.
All right,
fair enough.
That's because most brands focus on selling flashy gimmicks rather than better
brushing,
but not quit on that.
These guys have quit.
So what makes quip so different?
You may have asked,
maybe didn't ask,
but I asked for you for status.
Quip is an electric toothbrush.
That's a fraction of the cost of bulkier brushes on,
it's a guy I didn't know it was electric.
I have a gas toothbrush a while still packing,
just I have to hook,
plug it into the stove or plugging it.
That will be electric bill.
While still packing just the right amount of vibration to help clean your teeth.
Quip built quips built in timer,
helps you clean,
uh,
for the dentist.
Recommended two minutes with guiding pulses that remind you to switch sides.
Next quips subscription plans are for your health,
not just convenience.
They deliver new brush heads on a dentist.
Recommended schedule every three months for just $5,
including free shipping worldwide.
Quip also comes with a mount that suctions right to your mirror and unstick to
use as a cover for hygienic travel wherever you take your teeth.
And finally,
everyone loves quip.
They were on Oprah's o list.
Jesus how full of herself as she.
This is the oldest,
uh,
Oprah's oldest,
like she literally named it after herself twice named one of Time's best
inventions and it's the first subscription electric toothbrush accepted by the
American dental association.
Plus they're backed by a network of over 20,000 dentists and hygienists and
hundreds of thousands of happy brushes.
Use Quip everyday.
Quip starts at just 25 bucks.
And if you go to get quip Qui p.com/bar right now,
you'll get your first refill pack for free with a quip electric toothbrush.
That's your first refill pack for free@getquipdotcomslashburrspelledgtquip.com
slash bar.
All right,
the fuck was I just going to go look up.
That made me want to look something up.
It wasn't for hymns.
I have no idea if I already forget.
You forget it.
All right guys,
I apologize.
How fucking sick I have here.
Uh,
just enjoy the music and listen to a half hour of a Thursday afternoon podcast
where I wasn't fucking sick,
hopefully.
All right.
God bless you.
God bless the United States that the applicant's Democrats and libertarians
people would love groups,
anti social people,
follow people,
people at the back of comedy clubs who had up business cards for hair plugs.
All right.
Have a great weekend and I'll talk to you about that.
Oh,
did you enjoy the 4th of July?
You know,
first of all,
right out of the gate,
right out of the gate.
I want to thank everybody that did some dumb shit with fireworks and it had the
presence of mind to fucking make a youtube video out of it,
you know?
So guys like make it just sit down.
I was laughing my ass off last night I went to bed and I was watching people
shooting bottle rockets out of their ass,
having a Roman candle fights,
seen somebody take one to the face.
Do you know some guy in Maine lit something off on top of his fucking head and
he died instantly.
They were like,
he lit off,
they said a mortar or something.
Fucking insane.
What could,
what kind of,
you know,
kind of a fucking asshole would do something like that.
He must have had it.
There's no way.
Everybody knows once you get up to anything like a pack of firecrackers on your
head you like,
that's,
that's funny,
you're going to fucking kill your ear drums and you know,
but you're going to survive.
But what would he put an mat in his mouth or something?
Well I dunno bill,
you fucking brought it up.
All right,
relax.
What's this look up?
Main guy dies.
Fireworks.
All right.
Shoots off firework from top of his head dies instantly.
A 22 year old man was drinking and celebrating the 4th of July.
Happy Birthday to America.
Don't put it on my head.
I'll fucking lie today.
Happy Birthday.
Wow.
Michael.
Oh my God.
Somebody calling me.
I'll do it.
Um,
that's how I went down.
22 year old man who was drinking and celebrating the 4th of July.
I tried to launch a firework from Trump.
Is his head killing him instantly.
Authority said
30 said,
you've got to be an authority to say that somebody is fucking dead after the
light.
Something off on their head.
Wait a minute.
Claire.
Claire,
the way.
Click yes.
Yes,
he is dead.
Well,
we kind of knew that you guys,
Brian's although the sidewalk.
Watch your mouth woman once your mouth woman.
It's one of my favorite quotes in sports over the last fucking,
I dunno how many months.
Six months.
Watch your mouth woman.
When that woman called,
uh,
asked the Braun what it was like to be a punk ass bitch and then that guy's
going to watch your mouth woman watch your mouth woman and you know,
you would think that the broads would've had such,
which have fucking difficulty with it.
Like you know,
I realized that she said something derogatory towards him.
Excuse,
go change your Bra Lady.
All right.
I love that they didn't say anything cause even they knew even they knew that I
guide.
Yeah that bitch was out of line.
I'm just talking shit today.
Um,
they won't say what kind of fireworks it was.
Okay.
All right.
Apparently he thought that was a great idea that have just,
when you died in a stupid fucking way and when somebody starts it off when they
start your yield eulogy off with apparently.
Yeah.
Apparently this Keto sticking his head in the garbage disposal was a,
you know,
going to give them a good buzz.
I mean,
I'm sorry to bring it up Claire,
but you know how did even get it in there?
Oh,
let Lou Ya.
Um,
his friends said they thought,
okay.
They thought they dissuaded him from doing it.
The next thing they knew,
he ignited the firework and he was killed instantly.
What the fuck did he shoot off?
Okay.
There was no rushing him to the hospital.
There was no Devin left when I got there.
Said 25 year old Cody.
Jesus Christ.
The names at this generation,
Huh?
Devin Cody
jeep wrangler.
Uh,
Devin was the kind of person who would do something stupid.
Absolutely.
He was the kind of person who would pretend to do something stupid to make
people laugh.
Well,
he wasn't faking it.
MMM.
All right.
It's the first fireworks fatality since they legalized fireworks January 1st,
2012 while he just fucked it up for the whole state.
It's bad enough.
Everyone's on heroin now.
You're going to give them fireworks mean.
What next does isis get their own juice store?
Come on.
People.
Over 80% of bottle rockets are shot out of people's anuses in this state alone.
Yeah.
This needs to stop.
Woo.
That's going on in main street right now in Maine.
Yeah.
Hi.
Do you know me?
Of course you don't.
I'm your regular housewife here in Maine.
My son is on heroin.
My other son shot a Roman candle up his ass.
I'm sorry to be graphic.
He was trying to shoot it out of his ass.
But apparently his excitement.
Okay.
What was getting who?
I mean,
in order to light the wick,
you've gotta be able to see it.
So I dunno how they think we're done.
When we were kids,
we just,
we let them and we ran away.
We hit under our desks.
That's what we did.
Devin was a great person.
Um,
and in New Jersey at 52 year old man blew off a large piece of his leg below the
knee when he set off a tennis ball size firework in Montana,
Montana,
a 32 year old man was killed at his billings home in a fireworks accident
involving a mortar tube.
Okay.
All right.
At least there was some sort of mortar round.
I mean,
mortar around.
first of all,
when you start light off shit,
well your neighbor starts screaming and comment.
You know what,
what do you think is going to happen?
Okay.
It's look up a mortar tube here,
everybody.
I'm learning about fireworks through the death of my fellow Americans.
Um,
I spelt motor.
All right.
Firework,
mortar tubes.
How about some images?
Let me see.
What the fuck these things look like.
Is there some sort of,
all right.
All I see is army guys.
Yeah,
that's not good.
You know when,
when the shit you're shooting off.
Okay.
Oh,
there we go.
Okay,
well there's one that looks like a little barbershop thing.
One off fucking dope.
He shot that off his head.
You know what probably happened,
I would guess is that there was some sort of discharge from the bottom end of it
and the concussive force,
but it seems like there was no Deviney fucking blew his head off.
You know,
Jesus want a way to start.
I had such a wonderful weekend.
Um,
I didn't mean this one.
I was talking about funny shit.
I was just talking about,
you know,
people haven't Roman candle fights.
Come on,
we all did that shit.
Right?
That's bait.
That is the evolution of all weaponry and all right?
Anything that has an device,
anything that,
that,
uh,
it's supposed to do.
Anything that,
that fucking blow shit up.
You just,
you start or you,
anything that you can shoot at a target.
It always starts simple.
Let's light it off.
You know,
let's,
let's point it in that direction at the trees,
right?
And then what?
Then you move up to a,
let's torture some insects.
Uh,
let's shoot a bird.
And eventually,
because you know,
the way human beings are,
that we always try to top one another and we get bored,
which is the reason why we went from walking to the horse to the car.
I'm really in deep right now.
I know.
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about.
Eventually,
you're going to move to the,
the,
the ultimate prey,
the human being,
you know,
something that can think the same way.
You do something that may have done better in math than you did.
You know,
that's the challenge.
This person passed Algebra.
I did not.
We're both trying to kill one another is,
you know,
first outside,
inside,
last gonna come into play here when we're out in the woods
are opposite angles being congruent?
Is that going to be the death of me or do I just have that extra something?
Do I want it a little bit more?
Am I able to block out the fifth commandment?
Do I have such a strong religious background than I can hear God's voice in my
head telling me that I'm right telling me to deliver?
That animal is not even a man anymore.
It's a fucking Hannibal.
Deliver that animal
in the express lane to its maker.
Right.
Do I have that?
I mean,
it's inevitable.
That's personally why I don't fuck with fireworks.
I don't fuck with fireworks because I know that I am scatterbrained and I get
bored easily and I have 10,000 fucking hobbies and eventually lighting it off on
the driveway is not going to be enough for me.
Okay.
I have neighbors,
I have neighbors that I get along with.
Maybe I'm bored with the fact that I get along with them.
Maybe I want to stop.
Maybe some days you just wake up and you just want to start some shit and you
just happen to have some fireworks that don't just blow up.
They go way up in the air
and you want to shoot somebody.
Right.
Anyways,
my condolences to anybody,
uh,
who knows somebody that died and I don't have any condolences for the people
that die because you're fucking dead and you either dead or I think you were in
a better place because someone who's dumb enough to blow themselves up on the
July 4th weekend with their own goddamn explosive,
I don't think ever had the brains to really hurt another human being knowingly.
I never knowingly lied,
knowingly hurt another fucking human being.
I mean,
honestly,
if you're that fucking stupid,
obviously could go out and hurt somebody,
but you know,
you really have the mental capacity to understand,
you know,
your actions.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's Belper and it's the Monday morning podcast for July 5th,
2010 one day after the birthday of this country.
Happy Birthday to America.
Happy Birthday to the USA.
Happy Birthday.
Fuck every other country.
You know,
like a Sadie way,
you fucking douchebags.
Um,
Jesus Christ,
happy birthday to one of the most hated countries on the face of the fucking
planet.
You know,
everybody's shitting on us.
All those fucking World Cup referees.
You know,
people tugging on our shirts,
kicking us in our fucking American balls.
They don't see any of it.
A reason why we're out of the World Cup is because of our foreign policy.
That's why,
that's why we were always off sides.
They never were the Ganges.
Does whoever the fuck kicked our ass?
I Dunno.
Um,
is the World Cup still going?
Is the world's still watching?
Let me ask the world the question.
When your team gets knocked out,
do you tap out and like,
yeah,
fuck the World Cup,
you know,
and you go back to your hut and your grind up corn in that little guacamole
bowl.
They do that.
Um,
what exactly is done?
Do you continue watching?
I mean,
cause I watch NFL football and when the New England Patriots got raped by the
Baltimore Ravens,
I continued to watch the uh,
the playoffs.
Playoffs,
yes.
Playoffs.
I continued to watch them.
And uh,
so I was wondering if you guys are so into soccer.
Yes.
And I am calling it soccer because it's,
it's our birthday this week,
so I'm not going to fucking cow down to you.
Motherfuckers had said call it football,
you know,
just cause you have a ball and you can only kick it with your foot.
You know,
you guys think you're so clever.
Oh,
that's real football.
Really.
You can kick it with both feet,
can't ya?
Why isn't it feet ball?
What's the deal?
Um,
look at me with a head of fucking steam.
I'm hung over to feel like shit.
Had a bunch of fucking 4th of July Barbecue,
you know?
Is it ever good?
Oh,
look at the ribs.
All slathered in fucking glistening in fucking fat and you get over there and
you stick your fat American face right into it.
It's all over your face like some fucking two year old trying to eat birthday
cake.
You know,
in your run your hand through your hair with it.
Get that fucking grizzled Moose look going.
That's right.
Then you have sex with some underage girl in a hot tub and you have to fleet of
France because in France,
that's a fucking acceptable America.
Um,
no,
actually I had some great,
some great food yesterday.
I just had too much of it.
I just could not stop stuffing my fat face.
I was that kind of full where I couldn't stay in one position.
I was like sitting down and then after a while that wasn't comfortable,
then I'd stand up for a minute and then that wouldn't be comfortable.
Then I had to like lean on the side of the person's house fucking with the
foundation at that point.
But it was a good time birthday of America and actually went to a party.
Uh,
there was just a little bit into the Hollywood hills and uh,
was looking out over la and it's absolutely fucking hilarious.
The amount of illegal fireworks that are shut off,
I dunno,
in every city or an la in particular because I've never had like a bird's eye
view.
And somebody made this hilarious joke that whereas we were looking out,
it looked like when America bombed our United States,
I should say the United States bombed a Baghdad.
And then as we were watching the fireworks going off,
they should have been like a little CNN logo down on the lefthand side of,
uh,
our eyeballs.
And then we all had a big laugh after this person made that hilarious joke,
man,
remember that shit?
You know,
it really made me feel like,
you know,
what the fuck
wasn't that a deep thought?
It made me think,
what the Fuck Gi bill.
I don't think you need to elaborate on that anymore.
I think you really summed it up.
Nah,
just thinking like,
what,
uh,
what would I be doing?
You know,
if,
uh,
if I was sitting in a city that was getting bombed and I worked in like a
fucking,
you know,
I was like,
ah,
I always say a hardware store for once,
Bill,
can he come up with a different job?
Uh,
maybe I put shoes on the bottom of,
uh,
lamas,
feats,
feet.
You know there's a Lama like is that like an Australian animal or is that from
the mid?
Uh,
I want to say the Midwest.
The Middle East.
Every once in a while you see a lama in this fucking country and it almost
causes an accident cause you like,
what the fuck happened to that ponies neck?
Um,
now it really made me think like,
I,
I laughed and then I felt bad.
Like where the fuck do I get off laughing?
There's nothing funny about war.
Even if we got to go in and we got to do the shit,
there's just nothing funny about it.
Cause there's a bunch of people on the fucking ground who had nothing to do with
shit.
You know,
they had nothing to do with that maniac and is Tom Selleck mustache.
They just trying to fucking survive.
And then these people come in there to rescue them and they end up getting
fucking blown up.
And then here I am,
feed my face like a fat fuck,
you know,
just full of pork,
corn bread,
some Nilla wafer dessert about four beers
and I my ball in a slice of pizza watching fireworks in the fucking Hollywood
hills.
Eh,
it looks like bad Baghdad.
We all should have just projectile vomited right there in a tribute to the,
the end of the Roman Empire.
He,
you know when they used to do,
they had those rooms,
those puking rooms.
He just sat there stuffing your face and then you would fucking go in there and
just puke.
Which is another fucking reason why these fucking European cunts really need to
sit down and read a history book.
They always talk about how dumb we are.
The exact same shit that they're making fun of us for.
They've all done two,
three times over every fucking one of them.
And I'd rattle off the stats,
but I don't know him.
Please.
You can tell me that little fucking midget Napoleon didn't.
Stuff is fat face a little fucking Danny devito look and Douche bag.
Huh?
What happened to him?
He went to Waterloo.
What's up with dad fucking Waterloo.
This is like typical fucking American,
uh,
Shit Talk.
And I know,
I know the major fucking players and I know the major battle names,
but I have no idea what happened.
He went to Waterloo,
which I believe was at an Austria.
Was that right down the street and Connecticut?
Where the fuck did that happen?
All I know is he went there and he got his little fucking ass kick.
Did he ride a pony in the battle?
Because he was so little that if he actually fell off a real horse,
it would be fallen off like a fucking skyscraper.
That little dose rubbing his fucking stomach.
Cause he had an ulcer because he has that little dwarf stomach.
They can't,
if they can't die,
Jess,
more than a couple of strawberries.
And he's sitting there trying to fucking dive in and be the big guy.
He won't,
you won't accept it.
Won't accept that he's,
he's a little guy with little Oregon's and a little intestinal track.
So what does he do?
He stuffs his face trying to Audi in his fucking drill sergeant.
You know,
eating a Bronto Burger,
whatever they did back then.
Next thing you know,
he's got an ulcer and this no pepto snow,
fucking Pepto,
you know,
it's the 15 hundreds.
Did that on purpose just for all you fucking snobs.
I know he was around in the 18 hundreds wasn't a hose.
It's 17 hundreds I dunno.
One of those ones where the,
where you're fucking,
you're wore too much makeup.
You know,
when you curled up your hair,
like that chicken little house on the prairie that I was making a reference to,
Nelly,
Nelly Olson,
who's got a fucking book coming out,
doesn't she?
You know?
See now that's how you do it as a child star when you fall off.
She never got involved in drugs,
you know,
she just kept fucking living off of her residuals.
Granted,
she had the options because evidently that series plays all over the world,
you know?
But now she writes a book,
you know,
you just keep milking it.
You just write a book.
Still Nelly Still Nellie after all these years and you answered the same fucking
questions over and over again.
How close was that character to the real you?
If they're a little bit and Nellie in you,
if they're a little bit of Nellie and all of us,
you know,
and people wonder why those celebrities end up snapping in those fucking
interviews.
Somebody sent me a youtube video this week about Mel Gibson who's having another
rough week,
by the way.
He still,
no,
no audio tape of him being a Douche has really come about.
I think that's just the,
uh,
the ex girlfriend claiming he did some shit like that.
Either that or he's got a fucking unbelievable fucking lawyer,
which,
you know,
could be either or.
But uh,
what the hell is it?
Where the fuck is a youtube video?
Oh Man,
I was on such a role.
What is my voice hurt?
Like I did a bunch of,
oh,
there it is.
Like I did a bunch of shows this weekend.
Was it because I was drunk yelling at people?
Um,
all right.
Uh,
Mel Gibson's,
here's a youtube video.
Look up Mel Gibson,
Dean Richard Calls Dean Richards and asshole and a,
somebody asks me my opinion on it.
And I think he was,
I think he was well within his fucking right to call him an asshole.
Basically what happens is this guy goes,
the passive aggressive route where Mel comes on to hype is movie and Deeds.
Like,
you know,
hey,
it's great to have you here,
but Ba,
ba Ba,
and he could see Mel Mel's already defensive because he's got that anti-semite
rant hanging over his fucking head.
So He's already fucking just,
you know,
he could see it in his face like,
oh fuck,
let me just get through this fucking interview without this guy bringing the
shit up.
So the guy that we fucking a he soft cells of whatever,
he did it passive aggressive.
Oh this about the movie that about the movie.
And then he goes,
yeah,
you know,
it's kind of some familiar ground.
I feel like I'm visiting an old friend,
which is a really country way of saying like,
yeah,
I've already seen you do this movie before,
but he doesn't come out and say it.
Mel Handles all of it with grace.
And then finally in the,
in the end,
you know,
he fucking suckers.
And with the overhand right going,
oh yeah.
Uh,
so how do you think the public's going to receive you?
And,
and he goes,
what do you mean?
He goes,
you know,
with a,
he's telling of your troubles that you've had in the past.
And Mel Goza,
well,
you know,
my life's kind of in a rollercoaster.
Uh,
and the guy just keeps going and goes,
what exactly are you talking about?
And he just fucking,
he cause you know,
when he got drunk and blah,
blah,
and he brings that shit up again.
And Mel's like,
dude,
he spent four fucking years,
Yada Yada.
Yah,
this is my thing.
It's like one of those deals where Mel Gibson,
he did say it.
So,
but my thing is if you're going to fucking trash the guy for it,
just go ahead and trash them.
Don't sit there and act like you're the guy's fucking buddy.
And then out of nowhere hit him over the head with it.
So he ends up calling the guy an asshole.
The guy is an asshole.
And,
uh,
the other point is that Dean Richards,
Guy,
I swear to God,
if you tapped his phone,
if you tap that guy's fucking phone,
you don't think that he would say anything that would involve some sort of,
uh,
apology.
I'm just really tired of people acting like they don't have any sort of fucking
issues whatsoever.
I'm not saying that you're a straight up fucking racist.
All right?
But you,
you never caught yourself.
You know,
you're walking down the street,
it's late at night,
you see some of them of a particular race.
And what do you think?
You thinking the worst shit,
you know,
and then it turns out for some reason you have to interact with them and then
their exact opposite of what the fuck you thought your were.
They were,
I mean,
I dunno,
I'm just sick of people.
When somebody does something like that,
everybody gets to be like holier than Thou and act like a,
they don't think any fucked up thoughts.
And second of Lee,
second,
second of Lee.
Second of all,
I think I'm on third of all if this point and,
and,
and uh,
see my,
my third point,
I'm just gonna switch between numbers and letters here.
Mel Gibson has a lot of fucking issues,
right?
So how do you cure the guy of these fucking hateful ish issues?
You're fucking drag them across the god Damn Coles and rub his fucking face in
it.
I mean,
I,
I really don't think that that's going to make a guy with fucked up thoughts
really sit back and reflect,
you know,
I mean,
it's up to that dude whether he wants to sit back and reflect,
but you know,
I don't think like a,
trying to think of a good fucking analogy.
I got it.
Like when I lived in Boston,
absolutely fucking hated the Yankees and I fucking hated their fans.
And then when I moved down in New York and I had to interact with them,
you know,
they weren't as bad,
but I still thought that they were Douche bags at the end of the day.
All right.
That was a bad example.
Whatever.
I fucking waiting the podcast.
You know what I'm saying?
At some point,
I think the public has to forgive Mel Gibson,
particularly anybody that he went off on.
I think he should be a nice guy to him and then he can realize,
wow,
what the fuck was I thinking?
Here's so and so.
He's part of the group X,
Y,
and z that I went off on.
I really was a drunk Douche bag.
But I think if you're a fucking racist country and you think that shit,
I think mace mostly,
maybe you'll,
you'll probably remain that way.
But if you're actually truly trying to not be a racist country anymore,
if the group that you attacked is a fucking asshole to you,
not a fucking asshole.
That's a bad,
but like just constantly is yelling at you.
I don't,
I don't see where you think that that guy is going to turn the fucking corner.
You know?
Where the fuck are you calling us?
Douchebags you fucking cunt.
Oh yeah.
What was I thinking?
You know what I mean?
Does that make any sense whatsoever?
I don't fucking know.
Whatever.
Look at,
I can separate the racist guy from his movies.
Uh,
I was kidding.
No,
it's hard to,
it's a,
it's,
it's a fucking difficult thing,
you know,
and the guy did say it,
so I guess he does deserve that.
But you know,
I just thought that was a really fucking pussy ass way.
I just thought if you watched the interview,
the guys being really passive aggressive,
he's taking swipes at the movie,
you know,
saying it's like,
oh this is,
he's basically saying,
Mel,
this is you doing shit I saw you do 20 years ago.
What's up with that?
But he,
but he was saying it in this,
you know,
I just felt like I was a visiting an old friend,
you know.
What about doing the stunts?
Is it harder to do the stunts now that you're older,
you know,
that type of ship?
Yeah.
Dean yet is harder.
Is it harder for you to see your Dick when you sit down?
When you take a shit,
you old fat,
fuck yeah,
we're getting older.
What is your point?
I'm trying to sell a movie here.
You take me out at the niece.
Why?
If you were just going to take me out at the knees,
why didn't you just do a rant on your show rather than have me get up at fucking
five and the Goddamn morning for you to pretend like you actually respect me on
some level.
I Dunno.
I guess that's my problem with the video.
Like I uh,
those of you listen to my podcasts,
you know how much I hate passive aggressiveness.
Um,
it's just a,
I dunno,
it's really a,
uh,
it's one of the bitchiness qualities you can have as a fucking human being.
You know,
if you're going to be a cunt stand,
they're flat footed with your shoulders squared up and just hit him a hundred
files going to say full force,
just like fucking Jeff Farmer who will be getting to later full force with being
a cunt towards him.
You know,
it's like you have a piss somebody off,
you cut them off and traffic and they're behind you and you're looking in their
face and you know,
they're mad at you.
Right?
And you drive for like two,
two and a half miles,
and then you make a right and it's still going straight.
And as you make a right,
they drive by and then they beep at you.
You know,
as they go by
back that type of shit.
Lean on the fucking whore and the second I do something right,
don't wait till I make a right turn and you could fucking beep at me and then
drive away.
Jesus Christ.
That was,
that was,
you know what?
That was a nice goddamn example.
That was really a nice example.
Um,
anyways,
I went out and I bought some new clothes this weekend.
Everybody,
it's,
it's kind of one of those weird things when you become an adult where,
uh,
as a kid,
I don't know about you guys.
I know these kids nowadays,
they're all fucking spoiled with their I pads,
you know,
and they have box of condoms or whatever the fuck they get at school every God
Damn Day.
Um,
I was just picturing people like 18 listen to this,
throwing their hands up.
Like,
what do we don't get that?
Um,
yeah,
there's that weird thing when I was a kid,
you got,
you got new clothes once a year.
You know,
Christmas didn't count because those were from your grandmother and that was
please beat the shit out of me.
Clothes.
Um,
I guess you got a couple of things,
but like basically you got new clothes at the beginning of every year.
That's how it worked in my family.
Beginning of every year.
You went down to the fucking Levi store,
you got like three different pairs of fucking quarter Royce and you got a new
pair of sneakers and you got like three shirts and that was it.
See you next September.
They're fuck,
oh,
that was it.
That was it.
And the rest was hand me downs from your older brothers and sisters,
not sisters,
older brothers or whatever,
or oldest sister's if you're abroad,
you know,
trying to fucking make this,
this podcast for everybody.
Uh,
what did I just sound like fucking Dana carvers carved George Bush.
That sounded like that to me.
Trying to do the podcast for everybody,
not Gani Dad.
Um,
wouldn't be prudent.
That's a terrible impression.
Bill.
Once you shut the fuck up and talk about your stupid clothes,
fine.
I will my podcast,
we'll fucking talk about whatever I want to talk about.
We think about that.
Um,
yes,
he got and that was it for the whole fucking year.
And you sneakers look good til about September 30th.
And then,
and then that was it.
And that was fucking it.
But uh,
but the weird thing as an adult is,
uh,
you know,
you think I'm going to say that you buy clothes more often.
The reality is is you don't,
you don't,
you let a couple of school years go by and uh,
then one day,
you know,
you have to go to an event that you haven't gone to in a while.
Like say like a barbecue.
I can't remember the last time I went to a fucking barbecue and you start
fishing out your barbecue clothes from the bottom of your God damn dresser
drawer.
You know,
bring a bathing suit.
I pull out this fucking bay.
Then students got a Mustang,
Mustang.
I can't even talk this week.
He has a mustard stain from like fucking back when Clinton was in office and I
don't know what it was now,
like I'm up on bathing suits styles,
but I could just tell it was not in style anymore and everything was just
fucking linty and old looking and all that shit.
So I was like God damn.
And I got to go to the fucking mall.
So I go to the mall,
I had to buy some new sneakers and I go into the foot locker and this selling
Lakers tee shirts that says 16 this is Los Angeles Lakers,
16 fucking NBA championships on it in the footlocker guy comes up,
dress like a ref,
you know.
And he comes up to me and he's just like a,
hey sir,
is there anything I can help you with?
I said,
yeah,
you can fix that tee shirt right there and have it say Los Angeles Lakers,
11 NBA championships.
And he's like,
what are you talking about?
I'm like,
cause you won.
Your first five is the Minneapolis Lakers.
All right,
sick Los Angeles Lakers,
it should say Minneapolis slash Los Angeles Lakers.
She got that Los Angelenos.
Those first five championships are not yours.
So why don't you fucking cave in your chest a little bit down to about 11
championships and I'll keep mine way the fuck out there with my 17 NBA
championships from the Boston Celtics,
all of them in Boston.
Are you guys still confused about that?
La?
Think about how many times have you burned down your city.
You haven't burned down 16 times.
You burned it down 11 times.
You fucking asshole.
Classic people from Los Angeles just pattern.
They're fucking resume.
You're a fucking PA on a project.
All of a sudden you're an executive producer.
You win 11 championships as the Los Angeles Lakers and all of a sudden now you
walking around with 16 NBA,
you got a lot of fucking nerve.
Just like tiger woods wife.
You got a lot of fucking nerve Stan the fuck down.
I don't know.
I can't remember if I talked about this last week,
uh,
on the podcast.
But after watching some world cup soccer and watching these fucking pansies,
every time anybody comes near,
I'm flopping around like they just got fucking tasered.
I was like,
you know what?
I Bet Pau Gasol,
that's where he learned his flopping around on the fucking cored out there.
Either that or you still watch a fishing show.
I can't figure out what he just outgrew the sport.
The big fucking goof.
His fucking face.
How do you fucking start squinting bef before you even start driving to the
Goddamn who rim.
If Pau Gasol ever puts out a ringtone,
that's what it's going to sound like.
He found me.
Oh,
I just can't get over it.
I just can't get over that.
We fucking lost to those assholes
and Colby choked and pile choke.
They both choked in game seven and no one's ever going to fucking remember.
If it wasn't for this podcast,
I'm going to be bringing it up for years.
Um,
all right.
Anyway,
so it's July everybody.
We're over the hump another year.
Another year is flying by.
All right,
and I want you guys to realize that it is July 5th.
All right.
In the end of August is coming.
So you make sure that you do something fun every God damn weekend.
All right,
so I don't know about you guys as you get older.
I don't know what the fuck happens.
It's May and you're like,
oh my God,
summer's coming.
And then the next thing you know,
it's,
it's over.
And you're like,
I didn't do shit.
I didn't do one fucking fun thing.
All I did was work and run.
As you get mad and you're going to hear actually examined how the fuck you let
another summer slip away.
All of a sudden it's preseason football and you get so fucking excited that you
forget that you wasted another summer.
Yes.
You guys a question.
When's the last time you went inner tubing down a God damn river?
Isn't that what you supposed to do in some sorta wrangler Jean Cutoffs.
Oh,
by the way,
by the fucking way,
speaking of wrangler,
if you want to know why that,
that,
that um,
reference was in my fucking head when I went,
I'm really bringing the voice down for this story.
Everybody when I went to go shopping yesterday,
which is one of the great activities you can do with your girlfriend when you
need new clothes.
I mean if you ever just want to watch your girl's face just light up,
just say that to her.
Hey Sweetheart,
you want to go shopping?
Oh my God.
He finally gets me.
Guess who I am?
I would love to go.
So we go over to the fucking mall and I'm like,
all right,
I need to buy some clothes,
some barbecue clothes,
some clothes that I can wear hanging out a barbecue.
So I won't get trashed at this fucking barbecue cause it's going to be a bunch
of comedians there.
I'd already get a bunch of shit if there was a bunch of pipe fitters down there
or whatever,
they would already be breaking ball.
So I got to go down there.
I got to be looking.
All right,
so we go to the mall and she takes me into target or is the women call it
Tarjay.
That's the little fucking,
oh my God,
we're being frisky.
Joke.
And this is the amazing thing about women is women can go into a target and find
something and,
and uh,
make it work as they say.
God,
I can't believe I know that fucking expression.
Okay.
I'm really going to have to bring up my excuse here.
My girl watches that fashion show and I actually am aware of that guy with the
glasses who goes make it work.
Um,
and this is basically how it works.
My girl watches those reality shows and uh,
I might even bring her in here.
Hey Nia.
Okay.
You want to come in on the podcast?
All right.
Knee is coming in on the podcast.
Everybody.
Okay.
I'm going to explain basically how it works.
When I,
uh,
the lovely Nia,
everybody,
I was actually,
I was talking about how when I needed some new barbecue clothes,
right?
That you took me to target and I was beginning to say that target,
like there's something about women that you can go into a target and actually
whatever you find you can make it work.
And then I realized that that was the same.
Yes.
So now I'm feeling like at work?
Yeah,
like people can be like,
you actually watched those shows.
How long do I last?
When I watch those reality shows with you?
About five minutes before I kick you out.
Kick you kick me out.
Why?
Because you act like a deck.
What do you mean?
I don't have like a dick.
I start GSA.
I start trashing the people on the show.
Yeah,
well you make little jokes and stuff and it's funny and then you get annoying
and you hinder my ability to enjoy.
It's like kick you out.
All right.
I want to defend my thing.
So she brings me into target.
I thought to go.
What's that?
I thought we were going in there for you to find workout clothes.
Workout clothes,
which,
so she brings me in into the corner of the store and she shows me these fucking,
I didn't even know champions still made workout clothes and they've since
changed their logo and she's like,
Huh,
look at these.
You like these workout clothes.
And it literally looked like the kind of shit you'd wear.
Like,
you know,
when you get,
you get arrested for something and then seven years later when they let you out
of jail,
they give you your clothes back.
That's what the fuck it looked like.
Basketballs or worth.
Yeah.
And I said,
yeah.
And they're also like the Jordan level where it's all the way down to your
calves still.
They don't realize that it's actually,
they found a happy medium between the Larry Bird's and the Michael Jordan.
Jordan.
Yeah.
Which is a little bit above the knee.
And uh,
so what did I do?
I went in there and I said,
I was in there for like three seconds.
I'm like,
yeah,
I'm not finding shit.
And you got fucking mad at me because the bill,
whenever we go shopping together and I have suggestions or whatever,
you just walk in,
look for not even three seconds are being very generous to yourself.
You walk in and you're like,
I'm not fucking doing this.
You don't even look.
You don't even take the time.
I was right,
but I was right.
They had tank tops next to like Dickies.
Sad like,
yeah,
like what are you going to snake out of fucking toilet and then go play some
hope.
It's not.
It's not for men.
Target is not for men.
I don't think it is unless the machine,
they're getting staff buy in.
Can openers and beard glasses.
That's what the fuck they're getting.
Then I bought,
what are they going to buy?
Slacks.
They had lots of slacks.
They had lots of tee shirts and stuff that you could have gotten,
you know?
Oh yeah,
they,
I could,
could've got some sneakers in there too with the Velcro fucking snap things over
the front as if to say I,
I,
you know,
they lost part of my foot in a boating accident.
They don't need to be that expensive.
If it's workout clothes,
of course you want to look nice,
but you don't have to spend a ton of money.
I don't know.
I don't believe in that unless you're a fucking tennis player.
If I were a tennis player,
I would want cute tennis outfit,
but if it's just me in here doing my stupid Jillian Michaels workout,
I don't know.
Once this might look,
well,
how did fuck did me going into getting some shit for going to a barbecue slash
some new workout clothes go to me wanting to buy a cute tennis outfit.
I didn't realize that this was supposed to be an outfit that transitioned to
you.
It was not an fit.
It's not an outfit.
Barbecue brought you in here to try to save face because I said make it work and
now you're just,
I'm just further into the muck bite.
All right.
That's it.
People.
I had to go to a barbecue and I went to the mall and I bought a cute outfit.
You did like you Nafa.
You looked really nice yesterday.
Yes,
I did.
I look respectable.
Although I did the classic old guy thing where I had the brand new sneakers in
the older socks.
You know what's funny is that when you were putting them on for half a second,
I wanted to suggest that you wear socks that were a little bit lower so that you
wouldn't see so much of the sock.
They were ankle level.
I know,
but you could've gone.
I'm like a little bit lower so I dunno.
I want to have that little ball on the back of him.
When did those become guys socks?
Chris Everett Lloyd's back.
But they're just the low socks.
You see more of the sneaker and not so much of this like I gotta be honest with
you and ask,
I dunno.
I have people write in about this.
I feel like when you wear shorts,
sneakers and socks,
if there's too much sock showing,
eh it's,
it gets a little,
I don't know.
Dorky.
Gotcha.
It's just class.
So you,
so you basically,
I'm the guy you love and you let me walk around this barbecue yesterday looking
like a Douche.
It's your own way to keep the women's away from me.
Is that what you were doing?
Didn't look like a Douche.
She looked really good.
And be anytime a while.
I don't know if we should get into this,
but why?
Why not?
What are we going to have an argument on here?
Do you think these people know me?
Shit about us.
We're trying to fill up and do an hour of their day at work.
Right now.
You're not mad.
They are that.
They have to work July 5th and the company crossed the street has a cool boss.
We're actually closed.
What is the problem?
No,
I just,
you know,
if I were to make a suggestion like that,
you really knew what to fork.
Almost [inaudible] book.
I was like,
what?
I sound like.
Well,
I remember making a suggestion yesterday and that didn't work out too good
either.
That's why I didn't want to bring it out.
Oh,
you don't want to talk about that?
You don't want to talk about the fact that I said your dress was a little linty.
Dell.
Your dress was a little linty.
Yes,
and we can then it then came home and I changed and this is,
this is the hardest like help guys out here you have it.
Do you know what the hardest fucking thing is when is when standing up now
standing up now,
cause I want to make a point here is it had nothing to do with you.
I was just,
I was,
you know,
I was like,
you know the drug you just dress had been worn just a little bit too low.
It's just one of those ones you throw over.
Look at me.
I'm already getting nervous trying to explain to you.
I said I'll buy you another one.
And then the next thing you know,
there was just like a fucking,
there was,
there was the meltdown at the mall and I use the meltdown,
started crying in the mall on the birthday of our country.
I don't give a shit about the birthday of this country.
Wow.
I don't,
sorry everyone.
Wow.
I'm African American.
There's still a little annoyance there,
so I'm not exactly,
yeah,
America's freedom.
Fuck you man.
To take it all the way to there.
Anyway,
wait a minute.
This isn't about that.
Oh my God.
Do you realize the emails were going to,
they're going to get,
well,
why don't you go the fuck back to fucking Air Africa?
They should say it.
Go ahead.
Let them get it all out there.
I know Mel Gibson's get it all out there.
Let's not mince words here.
Ah,
Jesus Christ and here,
you know I try to keep it light and you just went Fox News on me.
He just went Fox News on me or whatever.
No,
actually no.
The ultra liberal back to haunt me.
Yeah.
If I become a successful actress that this is going to be played on some sort of
website.
Nia.
Renee hates this country.
That's not what I'm saying.
But anyway,
what are you saying?
I'm saying that you know for,
wait a second.
When people celebrate 4th of July,
are they really like eating their barbecue in drinking their beer?
Thinking about this country and our forefathers and what it really,
no,
they're not.
They're just like,
Yay,
I don't have work tomorrow and I get to get drunk.
Yeah.
Most of them on the text messages telling people how before the July,
like it's Christmas.
No one cares.
I don't think
your popularity,
Nia was through
podcast and now you know,
it was funny.
It was,
I will listeners on a journey up and down a rollercoaster.
That's what,
that's exactly what Mel Gibson just said.
I just watched that thing and he just said that.
She just said that shit.
No,
there's fucking no passive aggressive Douche bag was sitting there going,
uh,
w w was came on acting like he wanted to talk about his movie,
but he really just wanted to sort of steer it back around to that time you went,
you went off.
So and then he was,
he was going like a,
he goes,
well,
you need,
you don't want,
when I saw your movie,
I just felt like I was visiting an old friend that we were on some,
some familiar ground.
He was basically saying like,
yeah,
I've seen this fucking movie before.
But,
but he was doing it in the sing song.
He fucking voice.
Very jerky.
Yeah.
So he starts with that.
Then he asked and he asked him about doing stunts.
Is it harder to do now that you're an old fuck?
Was basically the subtext and then in the end he goes,
how do you think America is going to receive you?
So then Mel had to play it off like he didn't know what he was talking about and
then he basically brings it around and then the end,
Mel calls him an asshole and at one point when Mel was sin,
he goes,
well,
you know my life has been sort of a edit on a roller coaster.
He did say that.
Sonia,
do you want to try to,
I didn't mean to.
So you do Gibson.
All right,
well look,
I'm not going to lie to you.
You guys did have a rough couple of hundred years there at the beginning of this
country.
Started off a little slow for you guys.
What do you mean 400 it wasn't a couple hundred.
It was those,
it was a couple hundred it was not.
It was go on line right now near this fucking country is only 230 fucking four
years old.
It is.
Yeah.
1776 that's when he officially became America.
That was 400 years.
400 Nia.
It's the two thousands right?
So that would be in the 16 hundreds you guys came over with those fucking
pilgrims and their butter.
What did they make?
Oh,
their oil.
What?
What do we use the pilgrim?
That it was one of this
old colony gas.
Nobody remembers those guys showing my age.
I don't know.
They came over with smallpox,
infected blankets and gave them to the Indians.
That's all I know.
Who did the pilgrims on the Nina.
The PINTA.
The Santa Maria?
No,
no,
no.
We didn't do the smallpox thing.
Like,
wait,
wait.
You're getting ahead of yourself.
We came over and we starve to death and then we acted like we were friends with
the Indians going,
hey man,
like how do,
how do you make quite sit down and have dinner with us?
Call it thanksgiving.
Yeah.
When I will kill you.
Why don't you teach us how,
right.
How to make it survive out here.
Yes.
And then once they did that,
we would just like,
wouldn't it be awesome if we all lived here and they didn't Hae Gebbie die?
Why don't you sneeze into these fucking blankets and we'll give it to him.
Yeah.
We,
we went germ warfare way back in the day and then we gave him like $48 for the
entire Midwest.
The Louisiana purchase.
No,
we did we buy that off of France?
Yeah.
Bought that off of France,
but whatever.
So that the French were over here murdering the Indians,
weren't they?
I don't fucking know.
All I know is they got,
yeah.
So gas is proving that we both can.
We don't know.
Shit.
Don't know shit.
There's a bunch of people judging us right now.
Well,
it's one of those things like,
you know,
like that type of Shit you learned and it just really doesn't come up in your
everyday life.
You know,
as I figure out how to get these bankers off,
my God damn back.
The Louisiana purchase really doesn't come up,
I guess.
Can you name,
can you listen?
Let's see how dumb we are.
Can name as many American wars as you possibly can.
Okay.
World War One and two,
Bang.
Don't want with the easy ones right off the bat.
The civil war,
uh,
Iraqi war operation.
Freedom as much called
the Cold War.
Was that an actual,
oh wow.
Wow.
My girlfriend's an idiot.
Wait a minute.
I'm not an idiot,
but no,
I'm not very good at history.
All right.
I admit it.
I'm not,
I don't know anything about here.
So then what are you trashing the country for?
I Dunno.
Can you just tap out and just say you're sorry.
Just say you're sorry.
Just say it.
Just say,
because what are you doing?
Do you think it's any better anywhere else?
You,
when you really look around the world,
where are they?
Where is everybody really holding hands and all getting along,
isn't it?
Everywhere that is they have and the Hab.
Okay,
let's talk about Sweden.
Let's,
Ah,
let's talk about how you only,
they only universal health care.
They only let good looking people in Stockholm,
Sweden.
And the second we got out of there,
we took the train out of there.
All of a sudden,
that's where they kept all the Brunettes,
all those Muslim looking dudes in that shitty fucking gray communists.
Look in mall.
We went to,
you remember that shit?
Well,
I mean,
isn't it sort of like Manhattan now?
That's not a good example,
but maybe in more,
you know,
you know international Richard Cities,
you have people who yes.
Can Afford to get their hair done once a week and have gym memberships and nice
clothes and eat it.
Just like here.
I know,
but I was just same thing.
It's the same thing.
All right?
You don't think those Blondie's look down on the brunettes and then a Brunette
Sco,
brunettes and at least Sweden we out within where the fuck were they?
They were there.
Yeah,
we were both walking down the street and Stockholm going,
Jesus Christ,
everyone's beautiful.
Look at that guy.
Yeah,
I felt like a fucking Mongrel.
There was hot guys working at h and m like model guy,
like,
like uh,
like movie star looking chicks working at like a newspaper stand.
Yeah.
And then what?
Remember that we got outside this Nia,
I'm telling you,
everywhere you go,
you go over to England.
They got their Rothschild's,
they got their royal fucking family.
You know,
they won't even mingle with those fucking people who work on the tube or
whatever the fuck they do.
Right.
And then people in London,
they look down on people in Liverpool and people in Liverpool looked down on
people in another city,
but I only know two cities in England.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
So there you go.
It's all the same shit.
What do you think?
You're gonna go?
You're gonna,
you're gonna move to where you're going to go to Canada and they're going to be
nicer.
Apparently they are very nice in Canada.
It's a really,
really,
you think so?
I Dunno.
He just,
through Toronto out there
every time anyone bringing up Toronto,
they have nothing but nice things to say about it.
So,
but no,
I've never been there.
So you know,
this was supposed to be a nice,
cute segment.
I didn't think that it was really,
it really wasn't supposed to be about,
oh,
you and your clothes are going to target.
Next thing you know,
you see?
Yeah.
Next thing you know,
you're having a reality moment hissy fits.
I am thrown at celebrating the birthday of this country.
Okay.
I am,
I am so mad at America right now.
I'm not mad at America.
This is a great country.
Of course it is.
But See,
took you 20 minutes to come back around.
It is,
I do.
I live life like living here.
I don't have a problem.
I'm not just like this fucking country sucks me in.
I'm not like,
man,
let me tell you something near,
that's how we talk.
Whenever we talk about hippy,
really liberal people,
we always,
we always end our centers with me.
And Yeah,
m y a n O,
and if you guys want to see the ultimate Hippie,
here's a,
here's a good rainbow guy.
Youtube video of the week.
Look up.
Uh,
you sent,
you sent to me.
Yosemite,
Yosemite mountain giant double rainbow.
This guy is a double rim.
Yeah.
You guys,
you have to watch this video.
Yeah.
This guy,
if he's on drugs,
he's the coolest guy ever.
But if he's sober,
he's one of the biggest,
he's such a Douche.
She had to live in the wilderness.
He basically sees,
uh,
a full on double rainbow.
Rainbow.
Yeah.
What does it mean?
And he starts fucking car.
I don't want to read it.
I don't ruin it for you.
Um,
here's another one.
I have like,
this is an unbelievable week for youtube videos here.
Uh,
Jones's good ass barbecue in foot massage.
Look that one up,
Jones is good ass barbecue and foot massage.
You've got to see,
and this is one of the creepiest videos at Brevard,
seen creepy,
weird hippie yoga teacher slash.
Farmer.
Oh my God.
Yeah,
yeah.
You got to look at that one and terrifying.
And then possibly my favorite
I've ever seen.
If you guys are wrestling fans,
you guys know how I love Rick Flair.
And when he got on the mic and started talking about who he was gonna fight that
weekend,
there was nobody better.
You got to see this look up.
Best Wrestling Promo ever jump in Jeff Farmer disguise the worst I've ever seen.
And he's so,
and that,
that's like four videos.
Like,
like the mean gene guy is going,
jumping Jeff last week that you know,
the one they actually do the gpt boy Jhumpa Jeff last week you got attacked by
so and so.
Uh,
you know,
how do you know?
And he really,
he really beat you down and then you're supposed to jump in.
Well let me tell you something,
come on this Saturday at the royal rumble,
but he doesn't,
he just goes,
you know,
and he really beat you down and the guy just goes,
Yup.
And then there's this
long awkward pause.
Well,
he turned the tables on me in a way that I didn't appreciate it.
I,
you just got to see it.
There's like four of them.
And uh,
then there's another person who actually,
uh,
what does this one,
fat nerd,
wow.
Gangster threatens x at all.
One that's all one.
And then it says guilties whatever that is.
S and off they spelt it wrong.
Or if that's a video game,
it's basically,
it's some really fat woman who,
uh,
got kicked off playing video games and she's a really pissed off about it.
And she starts showing some of the moves she learned in Jujitsu block strike.
It's really bad.
Just,
just check all of those out.
But,
uh,
it's almost getting to the point where I have to wrap up the podcast.
So Nia,
you fucking Pinko commie.
Thanks for coming on the podcast in spewing your fucking hatred.
Hatred.
I'm not a Cami.
I love this country.
It's like a love,
not love,
hate.
I know you got the love hate thing,
which I'll,
I'll never,
I'll never be able to appreciate as a white guy because my life is,
it's,
it's awesome in this country.
Oh,
perfect.
Anything you want.
It's tremendous.
I get a USA today and a bag of cash every day from the government.
Yup.
You're a white male.
Age 18 to 45.
Oh,
it's perfect.
It's,
it's bankers don't fuck me over.
Nobody's,
you need it to be.
Yeah,
it's tremendous.
No,
you love living in this country.
You love the fact that you can,
you know,
make something out of yourself.
You can really come from nothing.
And that's the thing,
you know,
immigrants come out with you.
It's really trying to save it right now
who don't speak a word of English.
And then they do rise up amongst the ranks and have a great,
like Cesar Milan,
the dog whisperer.
Yeah.
Look at him.
Yes.
He,
he did it.
He came into this country illegally.
Right.
Then he swam across the river,
like 12 dogs tied to his back.
Isn't that how we came in?
I think he did come illegally,
but he didn't become legal.
But so he's becoming,
yeah.
So there you go.
He has to,
I mean like how much money he's making.
Tyler Perry jump in.
Jeff Farmer Tyler.
Billy Carter are immigrants,
Huh?
Well,
yeah.
Oh,
immigrants.
All right.
Uh,
uh,
that fucking English speaking lady on.
So you think you can dance Arnold Schwarzenegger.
Arnold Schwartzenegger.
Yeah,
looking at him.
Kelly 40 yards in California.
He's pretty impressive.
Yeah.
Who love this country.
But there are some things that bothered me about it.
Like everyone else,
everyone else has various issues with this country too.
Maybe I'm not supposed to talk about it cause it's the 4th of July.
It's one of those things.
I know what you're saying.
Look you guys,
you know,
thank you.
You know,
you go down to the corner store next to no 12 cops are pulling you out of your
car.
You know,
beating the crap audio.
I get it.
Sure.
Yeah.
That doesn't happen to me.
I get annoyed this how spoiled I am as a white guy.
I get annoyed at airport security when they want,
when they want me to go through the little misty thing.
Are you a terrorist?
I get so fucking mad.
And I remember in that moment going like,
why?
I can't imagine how those Mexican dudes in Arizona are feeling right now getting
pulled over every five seconds yet.
I'm sure they're not excited about 4th of July this weekend.
Well,
what are you,
what are you supposed to do?
What are you supposed to do?
You don't want,
I don't understand social profile.
I Dunno.
You know what I think pat,
once the sun goes down and your outside everybody racially profiles,
you know,
you have to think the worst of people so you can get to your car in the parking
lot.
Okay.
Yeah.
If I see a black dude or Latino dude,
they're were in a gang.
If I see a white guy,
he's a serial killer
or a pedophile,
you know?
Right.
Okay.
Yeah.
White guys are either see a woman,
she's a whore.
She's a streetwalker.
We're not interested.
Lady children.
[inaudible] children.
They're a children of the corn.
That's,
yeah.
They just,
they just came out of the milkweeds.
Yeah,
you have,
you have to racially profile,
uh,
and at night and I think the bigger pussy you are slashed,
the more vulnerable you are.
Like someone like me never took any martial arts training.
I just said,
you know,
I got like about 700 fights under my belt all within my,
which is with my brothers,
you know.
So those don't count.
They have to stop at a certain point because they have to answer to your dad.
But like I,
I go out in the parking lot,
you know,
fiber fought off out there in the world.
Uh,
not as much as you,
I'm going to go,
that's the point I was going to make.
Like a woman feels more vulnerable,
right?
Yeah.
Like I don't walk around worried about getting raped.
The only time I have to worry about that is if I go to prison,
you know?
Yeah.
Knock on wood.
So what at what time do you start racially profiling when the sun goes down?
So during the winter,
during the winter,
it starts earlier,
like around five was going to say it's awfully early to start racially
profiling.
Now you know what it is.
This is when,
when,
when the second shift comes in,
if you know what I mean.
When the second shift comes in,
that's when I start racially profiling.
The beginning of the day,
people get up at eight in the morning when no matter what color you are,
you get up at eight in the morning,
you're a good person.
All right.
You worked at the end of the day.
Generally speaking,
you're a good person.
You get up at eight in the morning,
you're a good,
yeah,
you're a good person.
And make sure that serial killer who just goes to work every day and like,
yeah,
but I'm just saying generally speaking or got a fucking piece of shit on Wall
Street or a banker,
look at,
there's a lot of flaws in my theory.
All right.
But I'm talking about,
I'm talking about just like worrying about physical violence.
Okay?
You get up eight in the morning.
It's very hard to get your ass kicked between eight and five in the morning and
five in the afternoon.
This is what I'm saying.
But as a kid on the school yard,
there you go.
Exactly.
As an adult.
There you go.
So,
but after,
once the sun starts going down in the second shift comes out,
you know,
that's when,
uh,
like that,
that's when he know all of a sudden the fucking 28 days,
people come up from the manholes.
You know,
drug dealers come out,
the feeds come out,
depending on where you're at.
That's when,
yes,
that's right.
That's right.
The fucking stockers,
the guys with the date rape drug who honestly puts the date rape drug in
somebody's morning coffee,
you know,
do it.
What was the last time somebody got raped when the sun was up and the sun was
up?
I'm sure people get raped when the sun is no,
if you get raped from the sun is up.
You're asking for,
oh my God,
you have to top your,
I don't like this country thing.
I'm trying to bring some of the hate on to me.
Okay,
good.
Um,
yeah,
so I'll,
I'll,
I'll admit that I,
I'll admit that to you.
I,
yeah,
I racially profile at night,
but if there's a bigger group of people around and I feel safer than the racial
racial profile profiling goes down.
But seriously,
if I,
you know,
if you're a white guy with the shaved head during the day,
you have cancer at night,
you're part of,
you're part of a fucking Arion group.
Yeah.
I think I,
I would be nervous if I was coming out of somewhere or,
and there was a whole gang of white guys that were like look,
like they were in a Frat and they being loud and rowdy.
That would make me really nervous if I was walking and they would chant and rape
is rape.
Rape is right there.
The dude who do Jaeger bomber or some shit like that and they're all,
you know,
slapping each other on their back with their Letterman jackets.
That would make me very nervous to see cause because you saw the accused,
right?
I mean what are you basing this on?
I don't know.
I don't like those.
I don't like jockey kind of Frat guys anyway.
Great.
This is awesome.
It's such a great podcast.
Okay.
Cause no hot date.
Racy everybody.
Yeah.
See that's the thing.
Everybody does it,
which gets me back to this.
Everybody does that shit.
So,
and then when somebody and yeah,
and then when somebody steps out of line,
everybody gets to act like they don't think anything fucked up.
And I'm not saying it,
you know,
that I,
uh,
that this is something right about like,
look,
there's gray areas where you have to think the worst of people so you can get to
your fucking car,
unlock it,
get in the shit.
Yeah.
I got freaked out the other night when I got in my car.
I just immediately felt like there was someone in the backseat,
like one of those horror movies.
And then I was also nervous because I had been singing with the radio.
It's like,
great,
this person is gonna kill me.
And they think I'm a nerd.
Probably makes it easier to kill.
Yeah.
I'm going to miss this guy with this thing,
especially with the bucket seats.
It's so easy to reach around and just stab you in the fucking chest.
We're back in the day.
We shared the same car again and scare me now.
Okay.
Well I won't say,
I won't say that then.
Oh,
by the way,
everybody I've made the decision.
Um,
yeah.
Basically by you guys,
you know,
to like,
listen we're,
we,
we both exposed a lot of a ugly parts about itself.
So before you guys fire up for any fucking emails,
trashing my girlfriend or me or whatever,
look in the fucking mirror.
Okay,
go,
go look,
go look at your cookies before you delete them on the Internet.
Look at the last fucking 17 websites you went to.
So let's,
let me ask you that.
How about that?
There's a great podcast segment.
Let me here and I want to hear from everybody.
Men,
women,
black,
white,
Latino,
Asian.
I want to hear you guys.
I want to hear like some of the times when,
uh,
you know,
you've,
you've done your own little racially profiling or you looked,
or people who aren't white,
how you think,
how you look at some white people.
Cause I think that's really interesting.
Like you don't hear that.
Like it's always white people on TV.
We have to confess and apologize behind the podium.
Like my old bit go and like,
you know,
they had that rap music.
It was loud.
I got nervous.
I didn't realize that they were the swim team and they were just trying to get
amped up.
Didn't you see them in the,
in their little speedos?
I Dunno the music,
just blurt everything out,
you know.
So I want to hear from,
I want to hear from basically I want to hear from fucking everybody,
but basically times when,
when you've,
uh,
you've thought shit like that,
um,
or whatever.
I Dunno just the,
so we can get something positive out of this because so many times somebody
makes a comment like that,
like you made that kind of give a shit about the country's birthday and then
immediately that's,
that's the sound bite.
They tape and then,
and then it becomes all it then you actually get into,
oh yeah,
yeah.
Cause your uncle got,
you know,
got the shit kicked out of him because he,
his muffler was dragging as he drove himself to church in the cops felt that
they needed back up.
Yeah.
So,
um,
all right.
Yeah.
Okay.
So let's,
uh,
what was,
I just lost my entire train of thought.
You were saying you want people to write in all know ethnicity,
but I was going on,
I was going on.
There was one other fucking thing that happened yesterday.
He said I have decided to you guys speak into the mic.
Oh you said I have decided to uh,
I get nothing.
What was this about the car?
Oh yes.
No,
the car I want to get.
No.
Yeah,
this is it.
Okay.
My girlfriend's beyond fucking cool.
Right.
Sorry.
It was,
that was it.
There was a little bit of a poor coming up to,
I was like,
you know you get like that air bubble just comes up.
My girlfriend's beyond cool.
Um,
I'm going to get,
I'm going to get that dodge challenger,
I'm going to get it.
And I actually,
I was looking at the one down there with the fucking stick shift.
I don't know when I'm getting it,
but I'm getting that car.
I don't give a fuck if I get to get a used one.
But,
and I think it's hilarious because the stick shift one,
you actually have to pay a gas guzzler tax 1300 bucks out here.
Cause it only that's even better.
So I keep the fucking,
the passenger seat looking cute.
All right missy.
So anyways,
I think it's funny,
like it says,
it gets 14 miles city,
which means if you actually drive it like a fucking any sort of a man,
you're only getting like nine.
Yeah.
And how much is that going to cost you?
It's a film.
Don't fucking kill my fun.
All right.
No,
that's going to be,
the car will drive the Prius around like a couple of queers.
Right.
We'll do that.
And then it's a,
the cars to shit.
That's a great car.
It's like a great girlfriend.
She's a cheap date.
She doesn't want anything.
And then that'll be the horror that it bring out every Sunday the garage comes
up,
blah,
blah.
Okay.
That's what I want to do.
Make the tires squeal,
capture the last drop a youth I've had.
I know that,
you know,
cause I actually,
I looked at a bunch of cars,
I looked at it like those use BMWs,
I can't believe it's that someone already farted in this car seat.
You know,
where they try to act like they're brand new and uh,
I just think everything,
everything looks like a fucking Mercedes or a BMW and the,
that dodge challenger,
despite the fact that the Camaro's out there and the Mustang,
it's still is one of the most unique looking bad ass cars out on the road.
And I know it's American,
which means it can go fucking in a straight line.
It's the shit.
But if you take a turn,
unlike those slip over.
Yeah.
Unlike those German cars,
there's a little excitement with it,
you know?
No,
you don't give a fuck.
You know,
she,
my girl doesn't want me to get the car.
It's so much money.
Yeah,
no,
I get it.
Well that's why you're not,
why you cool.
Cause any of that.
Yeah.
Oh actually I might guide get that and I'm going to sit there whenever you want
a new guitar.
I said,
go get it.
You've earned the money to spend on it.
So go get yourself a new good.
Thank you.
And I look,
then you get,
yes,
are very supportive about giving me the green light to spend my money on myself.
That's a great thing.
You know what?
This is the long,
she'd been on the podcast and Nia,
I gotta tell you,
if you bring a lot to the podcast,
okay,
you bring your bring jokes,
you bring a bubbly attitude and you bring a little controversy.
You bring a little controversy.
I was really surprised.
But you know,
said I not have said that a no,
you should have because there's no way anybody's shut it off after that.
There's no way anybody's shut it off after that.
And,
uh,
I think generally speaking,
we'll get good emails,
but there will be a bunch of fucking douche she wants.
I would like to point out that back in the day I really wanted to get one of
those,
uh,
flag Bikini's
awesome.
So like hot and sexy and whatever,
but then you go,
if you really look like a trashy,
especially if you wear it in a different country,
if you buy one of those Nia,
I will learn to ride a fucking motorcycle just so you can be on the back with
your booty crack peeking out.
He out of the flag.
I saw that there's no way for a woman to ride on the back of a motorcycle
without her fucking underwear hanging out.
I saw this skinny girl was on the back of a bike yesterday and her entire like,
you know the Thong where you have like,
it's not,
it's not a g string,
it's a thong.
So you have that slice of Pie,
bit of fabric is hanging out.
The top of it was where,
where the,
the tramp stamp tattoo should have been by the time she leaned forward.
Yeah,
it was great.
It was America.
Speaking of which,
I saw a girl,
a couple,
well I saw her at this,
this last pool party I went to and she's a great girl,
but she has a,
uh,
made in the USA Tatsu in the tramp stamp area.
Wow.
God bless her.
She's a great girl.
And I said,
oh,
so are you,
you know,
and the,
the,
the armed forces or something.
Fuck the whole base.
No,
she was just like,
I just love this country.
When you put the microphone,
there you go.
I love,
I love what this country stands for and I'm really proud to be an American.
And I said,
all right,
you let her get away with that.
I mean,
what was I going to say?
Okay,
I respect that.
But were you going say,
cause I thought,
oh,
I'm just really patriotic.
Yeah,
no,
you're,
you're right.
Just kind of accepted it.
She said she,
I asked her,
she gave me an answer and moved on and now exposing her on the podcast.
You are,
you were talking about how like,
you know,
cause I'm always looking at cars right on the Internet and all that type of shit
and uh,
he was saying why do they always have like the women draped over him and all
that?
Cause the whole thing.
It's that guy visual thing.
You know what I mean?
Like when I,
when I look at the,
I'm not glad you,
like when I was looking at that challenge or I actually got,
I got a little aroused and I'm not even,
I'm not even joking.
No,
I'm serious.
Remember how you wanted to get off the lot.
But I was sort of lingering with one of my hands in my pocket.
I had filled up a little bit.
I know,
but I'm saying like she is tapped into that with that made in the USA thing.
Um Oh.
Like guys will be into that,
that whole sort of like fuck.
And I got a bear.
I got a fucking car and this is my fucking woman.
4th of July you got a sparkler.
She's blowing you.
She's actually a lesbian.
Is she good looking lesbian?
That's where I draw the line.
Oh,
there you go.
Okay.
Yeah.
I have no tolerance for not good looking lesbians.
I'm really a snob when it comes to this salary.
Right.
A lot of lesbian.
I like,
oh,
now you just dug the hole again.
There's ugly straight people.
There's ugly lesbian.
So what do you,
what did I like good looking lesbians and I like to do,
because you're a straight man that has a fantasy of being with like a couple of,
I'll just check off in the corner like a gentleman.
I would rather you admit to wanting to have a threesome with lesbians and say,
Yo,
I want to be brief.
I want to wear a ring.
Yeah.
Like I'm in my creepy years,
I'm 42 dark socks pulled up to the knees when tips,
sneakers,
shoes.
I mean,
um,
no I don't,
I don't have like any,
uh,
I don't have any,
I have zero tolerance.
Be attractive as a lesbian step up your game.
I have had it.
Why Mediocre looking glass?
I didn't realize it was such a problem.
There is one group of people in this country that I think needs to get out.
Take the hitch off.
Maybe they're talking about these illegal immigrants.
As long as you're good looking,
you can come into this fucking country.
I am equal up kick ugly.
Yeah.
That's what I get to stay for some reason.
Well,
you're not ugly,
Huh?
Uh,
right.
Attractive.
Okay,
please.
What?
Please,
how hard did you laugh the other day when you,
you,
you would put those little fashion fucking slits in your,
in your jeans.
And I was joking that I was going to do it my jeans.
I said,
what would you do if I showed that to my jeans?
Exposing my creamy thighs.
How hard did you laugh?
I'm a fucking mutiny.
I'm one step away from being a fucking albino.
All right,
we're,
we're like,
we're like an hour to minutes in here that very controversial.
Nia Renee Hill.
Everybody look at that took up like an hour of your day.
Happy fourth everybody forth.
And uh,
I'm sorry if you had to work today,
I hope this,
uh,
this podcast made it a little more enjoyable.
Ed.
Hey,
can I get a God blessed the troops or something from your neighbor?
Absolutely.
God bless the troops.
100% there you go.
There you can go perform for them.
They're doing a lot.
So you want me to go do that Gig on the front lines?
I'm going to fucking do it.
I think you should be doing that.
And I'm getting the fucking challenger America.
They don't get nearly as a pre.
I mean,
everyone says they appreciate the troops,
but I don't know that they get a lot of love,
especially from people who are anti this war,
but they're doing a lot of shit that most people wouldn't do.
So I commend them,
which goes back to my brave,
my bit,
that bit that I was doing when they was saying,
being a mother,
it's the toughest job on the planet.
Really?
Go fight a fucking war lady.
Put j Brown.
I go make a pie.
It's America's mattress,
America's birthday.
All right,
thanks for listening to everybody talk to you.
[inaudible] [inaudible].